now it's dipper right cuz this is second
time they've context now you got your
perspective one of our guys shows up
here he shows up with weed in his
backpack we go downstairs they gotta
check everyone's best ha so I go put it
in your pocket like I don't know what
you thought was gonna happen at this
thing anyway right bro
so he goes like a lot so why couldn't he
keep it on the bus who's he scared was
gonna disappear I am I know why he
thought to not keep it unless he didn't
want somebody [ __ ] take it in the cut
the whole time no not it not interacting
doesn't look like he's interacting with
anything you're saying right we leave
Sean takes us to another room down the
hall and I go oh look now the cameras
aren't honest like what's everyone think
what's your takeaway like this and he
sits back and he goes yo Reynolds I'll
need all this [ __ ]
he goes but I can never go back to what
I was doing before and doing the same
dumb stuff that was almost two years ago
my man moved out of West Philly used to
sell drugs in the corner of West Philly
and like for real like that was we
walked out of here and he was like
that's it like I'm just that's the
switch and so I I appreciate you taking
this time because that's that's the
that's the game the game is let me get
you out of what you're used to if you
can see it I think you can really be
it's really [ __ ] crazy right because
it's crazy to me that like one sentence
from and it's happened to all of us it's
happened to me like once I mean happens
with mute it's why people [ __ ] with
music so much like one sentence at one
moment at the right time just changes
it's crazy I'd like to think you know I
didn't know that that's something I
could do to think like that like in the
last couple years I'm like wait a minute
and obviously like look when you're
younger you're more moldable you're not
further along in your thinking obviously
what's uniquely interesting for me at
this point is Instagram is so important
to everyone's attention it's no
different than if I was like winning on
MTV in 19
- right like it's why did he won he was
so smart he just crashed TRL you know
and just was always show up cuz he know
the he knew the youth was on watching
that well that now is Instagram right
and so like no matter how much any of
the kids here like may want like would
either you know now it's different right
because this is second time they have
context now but even if they left like
but like when they go in the van and two
hours later they look on Instagram and
they see little baby or gonna or little
kid giving me love they're like wait a
minute that's just truth that's just how
it works and so right now I know I have
that responsibility when when NBA
players and rappers think I'm cool
inevitably that means an entire
generation of youth is gonna think I'm
cool and I'm speaking some real [ __ ] the
end and now it flipped for me too it
flipped and you know obviously that clip
a lot of people saw huh that's like a
great kind of my belief is that if
you're a great drug dealer you'd be a
great businessman I just believe that
because it's the same game there's a lot
of drug dealers that suck at it I look
at my man loose he's breaking down these
bags and some nickels because he's
making more money that way and he's
chanting he's actually making $3 bags
but he realized that everybody at the
school doesn't know the [ __ ]
difference doesn't care he's smart so if
you're good at it
or if somebody's if somebody's good at
it
they'd be even better at flipping
sneakers or gear or go into the thrift
store and flipping because it's the same
[ __ ] move like a great class I know
who it is
you know like did a lot of it like you
do get it up about that joke but it was
really good and be back in this space is
great and I never thought I could do
this cuz where you were talking to us in
the first video you said you want us to
come back 10 15 years I do
I can't see therefore it like I could
have started dealing you the day after
for a year and a half and then we get
Alexander it was like I'm like yo this
is some front this is like not the real
thing so anyway I was it's just so
incredible so so probably you know round
that time maybe six months early maybe
six months after I was like [ __ ] now
it's a responsibility which is heavy you
know I don't know it's just right I
don't know what to say like I'm in a
weird spot in my life where I'm like
[ __ ] I'm uniquely a human that can
penetrate fifteen to twenty
five-year-old alphab dudes and speak to
them in some way that makes them
actually see it different and there's
nothing else to say and now it's like
it's heavy and super like I'm grateful
but it's different I don't know it's to
say it's different not really you know
what's funny it no actually I answered a
funny way it's a really great question
it makes me not want to become a
caricature of myself the biggest thing
I'm scared
it doesn't make me watch what I say
because first of all the recent
fifteen-year-old kids will listen to me
is because I speak in a way that is
unfiltered and truthful and like like
when parents had me up there like hey
like I love your message cuz I'm talking
really good stuff they're like but you
know cursing I'm like mother [ __ ] do
you understand your kids only listen to
because I cursed it just feels more real
like well it's not what you think your
13 year old doesn't hear [ __ ] like you
know
here's a wrapper and yeah sure my dear
are you confident music in his head no
and I was like really surprised because
I do music and I'm very confident when I
do that I took the time out of my day
like they're learning on how to do it
all about myself and figure it out and I
wanted to know like what was voyages
like how did how you like explaining the
rappers how you can get your music out
there or - for people that's my that's
my problem I can meet great music I can
make guests on the music and do it on my
home I'll learn how to mix master
produce and all that stuff on the soap
how do you take it to another level
it's just exposure man like you know you
decided it's good the market hasn't yet
right so the biggest thing like some
people are insecure and think their [ __ ]
sucks and it's amazing and some people
think their shit's amazing and they're
delusional and sucks the the great part
about this world is you and I might have
brought this up when the crew was here
last time like you know because of the
college I went to like every one of my
friends wanted to be a rapper right and
I remember being blown away that they
weren't putting in the I was like get a
job at Kmart they're like I can't afford
time in the studio right that was that's
right that was my big thing with them
but what's crazy now is actually you
guys don't have to do that because of
technology and distribution all you have
to do is make music and then instead of
working at Kmart for 57 hours a week a
month or whatever and and then get
studio time and bang out one thing now
those 57 hours after you make the music
is just about DMing people and just
trying to get on your 1d at your I would
literally make music then lay in bed
until Instagram blocked me from DMing
people from right from you know play
bore cardi down to like a mean page that
needs music right from savage to [ __ ]
worldstar to somebody a booty girl like
I don't care just somebody to listen I
mean you know I think people are very
confused PB Brock got big because Kylie
had one little snap and people heard in
the back
like it's it's just this real like
that's how music works but what's
amazing about music is your one hit away
from everything changing and what people
don't think about is distribution they
think about making the music and then
they play within their own head like
it's good it's better like why are all
these people hitting my shits better
because nobody heard it so but the fact
that you could upload it to SoundCloud
and Spotify for free I mean I promise
you like the 39 to 74 year old versions
of you who are watching this right now
they're like yes speak it to that kid I
used to have like we didn't have a shot
we have it we didn't have a shot we have
this go-to in Midtown and give out our
CDs we had a pray that Run DMC saw like
you know it was like winning of the
lotto
it's not winning the lotto anymore you
just upload your [ __ ] I mean it you
upload every [ __ ] song every day
whatever and that's one of my favorite
clips ever just like watching your we'r
right there just your eyes it's the best
man it feels so good it's so it's so
real like that advice I give you is real
literally one time you're gonna DM some
bloggers and they're gonna put it in
their vlog and your life will be
different if it's the right that's good
it's just crazy it's very rich it you
you kids have it so much better
I don't know I mean cuz you know and and
they think it's cliche like you know
it's just not it's not like the old
school stuff like you have a better
because people did incrementally you
jump like 10 spots because the Internet
is neutral the Internet has no feelings
has no prejudice has no feelings has no
assumptions has no
tendencies doesn't care about anybody
more than anybody it's just there
somebody was crying this morning I was
on Twitter they're like [ __ ]
Instagram not getting the reach anymore
us artists we're getting [ __ ] kicked
get as many people seeing it now they
want us to pay [ __ ] [ __ ]
Facebook and Instagram
I replied I'm like shits free I'm like
what do you mean they're taking away
your [ __ ] it was it's free then I go I
didn't think about it that way it's free
oh right because they were smart and got
on early so they had more value but they
got they became entitled they didn't
know what they had until it goes away
it's the way we could live in
constraints of society and things that
nature you have to accept everything has
constraints you have to accept and you
have to understand your constraints can
become your advantages instagrams
[ __ ] you maybe it's now time to start
your podcast get your YouTube figure out
Facebook cool I like attention but
[Music]
that's fine too
I will tell you right now bye wait I
like that you're doing something
everybody's just debate and [ __ ] in
their head talking to their friends
about what they're gonna do the fact
that you're doing something's already
exciting the [ __ ] out of me I'm gonna
tell you something I really believe in
you have to lay in your [ __ ] bed and
DM until Instagram blocks you and then
go to sleep and wake up the next morning
and be like [ __ ] back to patience [ __ ]
nobody replied Gary's wrong do it again
the next day
the next day and then for some unknown
[ __ ] reason
young thug decided to listen to it and
your whole life will change if it's good
never and here's why you don't give up
you here's why know if it's good
not a the market will tell you my big
thing is if you want to be a music star
like what's up like why is it so scary
to to waste an hour before you go to
sleep like you're on Instagram looking
at pretty girls anyway the [ __ ] are you
doing anyway you you're on Instagram
anyway you're going to sleep that way
anyway so instead of watching basketball
highlights or boxing highlights or
pretty girls or just work if you want
something you got to work that is never
gonna change no internet no internet no
[ __ ] we all move to Mars you want
something you got to work but people
would rather complain about how it is
then put in the work people would rather
default into why they can't then putting
in the actions that allow them to ken
here's the biggest thing about that the
only people that are listening to you
are other losing players your honor the
only other people that are co-signing
your excuses are other losers okay as
you provide now you because I don't
really still get that but when IBM do ID
and countless other people so John
Travolta's Jeff's dude right you only
said I know that walking back hotter on
bu D and I started eating at everybody
from him the Ray Liotta Martin Scorsese
like I was going down and so here's what
I would say start over and go with this
hey I know you're busy as [ __ ] I have
unlimited sweat for you just like that
I've unlimited sweat equity I will work
you want to get you want to get coffee
cool you want me to edit [ __ ] like I
don't know what you everybody listen
everybody's either got money talent or
time and if you don't know what your
talent is yet and you have no money you
got time you got seven hours from Martin
Scorsese
so the biggest problem is when people
hit up people they're asking for
something instead of trying to give
something set the tone from the gap be
like I got time for you I'll tell you if
you what's so great about being young a
lot of youngsters do have creative
talents because you guys grew up in the
Internet we're making [ __ ] came natural
that we didn't grow up with you know so
listen every one of one of things I
think everybody should be doing so many
people trying to get to athletes and
rappers that are good at video and and
like editing an election I'm like make
[ __ ] for people it's mindset it's EQ its
optimism it's like this is just this
game it just is it's at this game you
can't start doing any of this until this
is right this is broken you're [ __ ]
you're just going through the motions it
to me it looks like waking up and
realizing whatever adversity they think
they have it's actually their biggest
strength they're not soft being an
african-american in America immediately
defaults you into not being soft and
that's huge that's it's true it's true
and you can be the most wealthy and
obviously that makes it easier but you
could be the richest and you're still
gonna be profiled and judged it's just
true and I think that's an advantage in
the way the world is going now because
their worlds playing out on the internet
where the internet doesn't judge that
that's how I see it
you know either I'm gonna be
historically correct or I'm gonna be
wrong but the opportunity is endless
like all the people there were humans
that made decisions in the 40s 50 60 70
s 80s 90s there were humans that made
decisions of who was gonna win and who
wasn't gonna win
there was humans there is no Sally
Spotify it's Spotify it's not Sasha
SoundCloud it's SoundCloud its platforms
that's why so much is happening now
I feel like one of the things you I hear
you saying to and I think this is
important for these guys is like not
being loyal to a particular platform
right that's for sure your I mean it
looks like you're all over the place all
the time course did you like so but
there's the grand and I think and
everything I see doesn't make me fear
Instagram going anywhere so quick but
like yeah of course if you're a creator
or you're trying to build a personal
brand or trying to sell t-shirts or
whatever you're up to like diversity
right can't be can't be vulnerable
myspace was the hottest [ __ ] it wasn't
even an app so what about is there any
concern though for like you have I don't
know 6,000 people following on Instagram
we only have 200 on Facebook why you
wasting time putting stuff on Facebook
more term thinking versus long-term
thinking that was a switch that you know
sure right now so start making every one
every other 10th post on your Instagram
be like you'll follow me on these things
I get it
that's the best part because then then
what happens is once you start once
people understand that giving actually
creates you getting [ __ ] gets real
interesting it's hard to think that
because people think it means you're
soft people are so scared of somebody
taking advantage of them
I've never in my life thought about
somebody taking advantage of me I gave I
didn't expect to get anything from it
you can't take advantage of somebody
who's given with no expectation there's
got [ __ ] pride its insecurity
so so my title at the school is a
janitor right so every morning they want
me to clean up after reaction yeah why
is that happening a great question
because I do so much more
got it then clean up got it got it
that's the official title you guys are
[ __ ] class that's why he's for
teacher he's strategic so I say that to
say they don't know where I came from
yep they don't know how many people I
put on shirts that I watch on TV oh I
love it
and they never call back and say here
goes a check for you thank you yeah of
course you know what I'm saying so it is
and it's and it's not why you're doing
it
no but I'm creating a dome over there
free and now I have freedom 100% without
[Music]
that's strategy I'll get to in a minute
let me see but anybody anybody who
hasn't asked everything any questions
thoughts actually I do right here so you
go next you know I'm a senior high
school yeah always say I always think
about my future everyday like I know why
people say oh don't think so far to the
future but should I have to because I
want to see where my self is like five
to ten years from now like my beep I
don't thought real quick being
thoughtful about the future is amazing
but not letting it [ __ ] you as the
key yeah cuz my problem B I would think
so first in the future I would start
worrying about stuff yep I want to
accomplish before I leave this earth
years from now that I want to do like uh
it's great to have ambition yeah yeah
that's that's but if you cast too much
judgment on yourself on a day to day on
how you're reaching that ambition you're
gonna [ __ ] yourself so you know like
having ambitions amazing yeah but if
you're like oh [ __ ] I want to be the
president United say so what the [ __ ]
did I do about that today you're gonna
lose yeah you know I mean like just see
a lot of videos and you and our wife
like saw what Eric Tom business yep he
speaks to me a lot cuz I'll watch my
step there's some song yeah but workouts
go to the gym boy yeah I've seen that
video bottle I'll watch it this past
week and you mm yeah but nothing is like
I always so think further in the future
that I will always worry about the bad
things that could have me started a good
thing yep because I'll put someone's
focus on what can go wrong you haven't
go right so what can you tell me that
but first of all the fact that you even
understand that to be true means you're
halfway home I'm being dead serious if
they're the fact that you understand
that that is your perspective means
you're on the cusp of fixing it need to
know now my my only thing that I've ever
seen really work in this scenario where
your DNA and your experiences has made
you look half glass full pessimistic
versus optimistically blind is to
fundamentally surround yourself with
optimistic people and optimistic
thoughts straight up okay the only thing
that I've ever really seen change people
is other people you got a cut out it's
real simple you got a cut out
pessimistic in negativity and you got it
and on optimism and positivity it's as
simple as that I've never seen it work
any other way well the only way I think
you can get there is to recognize who
else is in your inner circle I'm talking
family friends what's that I know it
does it's the people around you are they
spitting like negative [ __ ] it's always
you know if you're around somebody who
no matter what it's like see we're never
gonna you know that's what you believe
and then if you know so yep you can't I
don't believe in firing your parents or
your sister I feel in limiting your
exposure to them yeah but then and in
that limitation adding on like you guys
should be looking around at each other
and whoever else is in here and like in
order who's the most optimist and not
don't there's a real fine line between
delusion and optimism I'm gonna be in
the league but they're not even
practicing
so that's delusion I'm gonna be in a
league and maybe you don't see it but
you see them at least doing free throws
5:00 a.m. to 6:00 a.m. every morning
before they go on the bus you know at
least he's trying 100% that effort
matters there are so many guys in the
league that [ __ ] nobody saw it in
high school because people didn't see
the talent they weren't putting up the
stats but they were putting in the work
and by the way there's a million people
that put in the work that he's not have
a talent I mean every league if I had
talent oh I'd be [ __ ] Dion 3.0 you
know I'd play all for [ __ ] sport you
know like I'd be in it but I don't have
that talent but I had that work at that
guy that mindset so I really believe
what I'm about to tell you and it's a
big thing for everybody in this room and
and the more difficult your
circumstances are the more likely you're
around pessimism the problem is all the
kids that have all the money on the
Upper East Side and Upper West Side and
have it real good they've got the
reverse they have it so good it's
delusion so it's like two sides of the
same coin either you have to too little
where you have to too much I used to I
believe what's happened now is because
the way the internet works the people
have too little have the actual
advantage not too
people have too much that's crazy it's
game-changing for this conversation it's
why when I go and speak to like a
private school I'm like hey shits
turning the other way on you
you think granddaddy's gonna take care
of it the Internet's taken over so I
think you need to that my number one
piece of advice of leaving here is
whoever the most optimistic person is
here become more friendly with them
straight up or if you got an aunt and
she's optimistic her I mean it it's only
people or what's in your ears right more
Eric Thomas optimism and work less
somebody singing about suicide and
pessimism it's not going to work out how
hard he speaks yeah he comes at it yes
like it like missing when he says
something about a person like dang
that's something I'm doing wrong that I
should change then it hits me hard it's
like okay
now I know and that's the beauty of the
game right now right like Eric or I are
there's millions of people a lot of
people have very similar to Maddux we
just all have different communication
styles different adjectives different
styles and that's how people find the
person that speaks to them mix it up you
know how much time you have five let me
get ten well just you knew I was gonna
get stuck in here okay it's amazing I
wanna be like great yeah please
tell me like you're not gonna make good
you're not gonna make a lot of money
there right I don't you don't need to I
don't really care about making money by
like how do my like lip block that like
how do I like keep doing what I want to
do with that like I'll be very honest
with you on some straight intuition [ __ ]
I don't think you're hearing them that
much just even the way you ask the
question I'm being dead serious with you
I listen very carefully and I'm more
vibes than I am like the words I
actually don't think you're hearing them
that much I think you want to be
respectful to them like I think you're
like I think it's I think you've a good
vibe about this question it's gonna be
your life at the end anyway let me tell
you one thing about teaching or anything
else that doesn't make you [ __ ] in a
million dollars a year the most upset
not happy people I know have the most
money that I know this we need to start
changing a conversation to happiness not
money you can make 47 thousand a year
and have much more stuff than somebody
makes 280 that depends on how much you
spend you might not be in a position to
buy every new off white on a teacher
salary but the question is do you need
that the reality is most people need it
just to flex in front of somebody cuz
they're insecure once you don't give a
[ __ ] about anybody's opinion you don't
need [ __ ] ain't gonna buy anything you
need nothing that's straight up man
young guys buy [ __ ] cuz they're insecure
they want to look cool in front of their
friends they want to get a girl it's not
super complicated least complicated [ __ ]
of all time that's why you want all the
[ __ ] you want the end once you don't
want that
one thing I will tell you about making
money and teaching the current state of
the way we package education will
continue to evolve in my heart I think
this man right here is gonna look at the
same teacher that he is in some kid in
71 years and he's gonna look at them the
same way that Dominique Wilkins or Moses
Malone or Hall of Famers look at players
now these guys walk around they're 57 63
80 years old they were the best players
of their time and then watching scrubs
sit on the bench making more money in
one week than they made in their whole
career I believe the way education is
packaged and sold in the future I think
he'll make four million a year he just
won't because he misses timing but as
the internet evolves he's gonna teach
the rect get paid direct I believe that
I do believe that I do you know what I
mean so your parents and the world are
right if you decide to go and work in a
public school system you probably won't
make the most money if you decide to be
a teacher that does it virtually because
you're such a young man in 21 years and
that's how people actually get educated
and parents pay you directly you might
make [ __ ] 7 million a year of court
entrepreneurs weren't cool 20 years ago
people didn't make money rappin
I'm really insulating smashing yep yep
yep what's up were like they pay me and
I parties like that
how about those them aren't even give me
a budget you know how would I go home
like you'll make a fad like they'll give
you 200 you'll spend 160 I [ __ ] love
it okay it's worth about let's take a
step back is your thought then like
seven years if you live in LA making a
lot of money styling people that would
be fresh how are you thinking about it
like the thrill of the hunt of the
clothes against who you're gonna dress
is fun of [ __ ] so one more time
do you want to be a stylist when you
grow up yeah a couple things one it's no
different than a music advice and you
should DM Ben Simmons and me like I want
to dress you and if he's in a weird mood
he might just say yes I don't think
people understand all you need is one
yes I can't believe people are willing
to play the lottery every day but not
the end people like people would rather
like try to go to the casino like
Turning Stone and take that ride with
four of their buddies and 80 bucks
then DMP like it's a much better lottery
so anyway that's one and two the other
thing I would do if I were you and it
was similar to the advice I gave him but
yours is even more direct do you know do
you follow fifty to a hundred of the
biggest stylists in LA I think you
should if you ask me I would go Google
on the bus ride home right now top 100
stylists go follow all of them on
Instagram see who you think is fresh and
then DM those 57 and say I want to
intern for you for free and then when
one of them eraqus is the gas and you're
like [ __ ] how do I get to LA now
this goes back to just grinding like go
on Craigslist and live on somebody's
floor like either you want it or you
don't
guys I'm gonna say one more time from 20
from 14 but [ __ ] it from 22 to 34 I
worked every day I went out no weekends
I worked every day every day for [ __ ]
12 years to build my parents liquor
business and left at 34 with nothing
with part ownership of the land the
liquor stores on but with a huge
mortgage which means I'm underwater with
a salary I paid myself even though I
built it from 3 to 60 million that I
never paid myself any real money started
over 34 after building a 60 million
dollar business patience and if you want
it you want it
I wanted it first I wanted to pay back
my parents from taking me from Russia
and giving me this opportunity being the
best parents all that love and wisdom
that they put in me is why I can give it
to you now I had to pay that back I had
a real I didn't want that debt on my
shoulders I wanted to really pay back my
parents like for real and now I'm doing
me and I started 34 and a 43 and I'm a
kid I'm a kid and you guys think I'm old
as [ __ ] so think about how young you
really are if you know what I mean like
17 43 felt like dead like dead when I
was 22 and came out and my cousin was 30
I thought he was the oldest [ __ ] like
old so I know exactly how you're feeling
but one day you're gonna be sitting here
at 43 and you could see the heads
nodding you're gonna feel exactly the
same I feel the same [ __ ] fire energy
optimism ambition heat that I did when I
was a junior and senior in high school
same [ __ ] same person same [ __ ] same
when Yuri if you could but if one of you
actually internalized and said that's
true
you'll get patient man you want to talk
about not stressing about the next five
or ten years if you actually felt what I
just said and you believed it which I
know is hard I get it
it's like you know it's like changing
perspectives hard but if you believe
that you'd be patient as [ __ ] you
wouldn't be so stressed like [ __ ] he's
talking like that you're 17 18 18 you
like okay double
I'm gonna be 36 I'm gonna live my life
completely over again from this from the
get and I'm gonna be 36 which is seven
years younger than he is right now
and he's talking like that slows down
you know they talk about sports athletes
like to talk about like you know like
your for me like yo why why are you
having such a good season something
happen everything just slow down right
that's how life gets to not just sports
just all of a sudden slows down I like
knows the best
everybody got knows he didn't get does
you guys would be dating somebody
completely different right now no they
left me we'll see you know maybe you
want me there's any ended up saying all
right you can do this like a program you
get paid for it I didn't want to get
move on yeah
what do I think about it nothing good I
mean what like what what what like what
do I think about it nothing like I'm
like I mean are you kidding me people
literally I'm watching people take all
my content build businesses and then
[ __ ] on me to try to build themselves up
like I see everything like none of it
bothers me do yours do what the [ __ ] it
has nothing to do with me like just keep
doing it keep chopping thing on them
[ __ ] you over is a second that you're
not spending on offense
looking backwards folks with your neck
it just does right like what like I just
don't know I like like there's nothing
anybody here can the most cliche [ __ ]
what are you gonna tell me your dad
killed somebody's under jail
you're you lost your parent like that's
real as [ __ ] the problem is it happened
you just can't like it you just have no
prayer it doesn't mean that people don't
have sympathy and compassion lots of
people have sympathy and compassion and
empathy for those things you just can't
do anything about it
but like I can't go back and like stop
that electric fire that made you go
homeless for six months or by the way
we're going cliche like urban tougher
like people cry in my face they're like
my grandfather left me 50 million this
is real I keep telling you this like you
guys here for me if you pay attention my
grandfather left me v crying my
grandfather left me 50 million and no
matter what I do my whole life whatever
I do my whole life nobody will say I did
it I was handing it and you know what
that makes sense to him because he wants
to do something he wants to do it's
gonna make more sense to him based on
his question do I expect somebody who's
[ __ ] got no money struggled their
whole life to cry for the person I got
50 million of course not cuz that's what
they're trying to get but there's a lot
of people that were handed everything
who now know they can't hide and
everybody knows they were handed
everything money thus anything they knew
that would have killed me that would
have killed me from the get so like it's
just perspective
I just believe your adversity is your
[ __ ] foundation of success I really do
I really really do I really I don't know
what I I don't think I'm I don't think
I'm at this I don't think I'm delusional
my big thing is like if you've ever seen
anybody do it then you can - if anybody
looks like you that did it then you can
- why they do it why they get out right
people just give up before they start
like my dad would tell me always you
always go to stuff in school like my
grades are slipping or something as well
if he told me I gotta keep fighting
that's what he tells me every day before
he goes to work in comes with me every
time you know I would just give up
before when it when it starts like I
will struggle with school since
elementary school I will always give up
at the restaurant failing the quiz then
I got better and better then I'll have
my mom's all slip up but then I'd be
like oh I can't let's keep keep letting
this thing get to me I gotta get myself
back up and gotta keep fighting go on
you need to kiss that man in the face
you need to go home tonight and kiss
that man in the face I mean it I mean it
man that's real man that's real that's
[ __ ] real man
you're lucky you have some people
there's a lot of people that don't have
that in her life
he's right cuz he knows the alternative
every generation had it worst don't get
it twisted I think that's the value of
this really Gary like back to what I
said in the beginning is like that if
you see you can be an idea right kind of
be kind of being even being in the space
of like what's going on here what you've
built a family grab out to Nick and find
out when we do Mike you a part I know
there's some comps let's make sure we do
the people that or that yeah not first
second so like just like being in this
space like where people want to be and
they want to work in it and like being
being out of off the block for a minute
and like it's like it's it and don't put
the boardroom at a pedestal
don't put this [ __ ] place in a
pedestal now the Energy's good in this
place the best I'm the best I get it but
but recognize the block is your
foundation you know like I mean it it's
so valuable I mean it grit is rare now
we didn't pay the piper in 2009 there's
guys I can't you're coming back 18
months later I can't wait to see you
[ __ ] in 14 27 years you're gonna be
like [ __ ] you were so right
you don't understand how much your
[ __ ] adversity is your foundation the
Internet is neutral
everybody here should be selling [ __ ] on
the Internet yeah man you have so much
finger clock I love people get me up
there like I ain't got like you have
like we're in America your riches [ __ ]
by comparison a lot of people in route
in 77 in the world seven point seven
billion it's contextual maybe not in the
best part of Philly but but like look
this America if you have [ __ ] home of
the bridge you if you have [ __ ] in your
closet that you don't wear you got money
you have to synthesize everything even
me everybody everybody you have to
synthesize their perspective there's so
much value to get out the old cuz some
[ __ ] is tried and true but then you have
to synthesize [ __ ] when they're saying
stuff out of them being sad that they're
not in their prime anymore so you have
to synthesize this is about you
synthesizing not everything I said here
is right for you give the synthesize
that's my guy if you carefully watch me
give a keynote like the one hour should
I put on YouTube that's Richard Pryor
Eddie Murphy and Chris rap a hundred
percent even the way I [ __ ] if you
like to watch the cadence of how I
deliver I'm like [ __ ] I was really
affected by those [ __ ] Richard Pryor
I mean I [ __ ] listen I I played that
tape out
[Music]
legend
let me sneak one or two more in who
hasn't asked question I'll answer it
cake that's like that's like my old yes
okay sorry but the thing is with being
teachers rusty and black teachers yes
cuz they're because they're like none
you feel me dick like it's so rare it's
it's like it's like it's like a freaking
golden goose you for me where it's not
as rare as you think yeah you're just
your perspectives limited let's start
with that because that matters because
if that's your framework then you're on
a different course like then you're
already thinking like oh [ __ ] I gotta
win the lotto and I'm like not even
really not really there's plenty of
african-american teachers in the world
there's lots of black teachers whole lot
whole lot lots and lots of course you go
one [ __ ] school you got a fake-ass 13
I don't give a [ __ ] you went to point
zero zero zero one percent of the
schools in this [ __ ] country I know
I'm right [ __ ] he's like if you
went into 13 schools there's [ __ ]
forty thousand school us you're keeping
it tight but it's important I said let
me tell you something both of you and
teaching I think is I'm doing it in my
way two things
one that's you know like once you start
thinking it's limited like it's gonna
it's gonna change your framework but Lee
it might be your strength that might
drive you to get it done so I don't to
take it away
I just want to make sure you're dealing
in truth right - you got to ask yourself
when you decided you wanted to be a
teacher one and this is just this is
just not about teaching if you said you
wanted to be a multi trillionaire you're
so young I'm coming you're so young that
you'd need to make sure that when you
decide in your thing have you evolved
since ideology is very dangerous if you
put in your head too early because it's
where you limited yourself or where it
was most comfortable or because you
loved your fourth grade teacher just be
thoughtful you're evolving every day I
say that these two they're both young to
just keep evolving so just that's just
something I want to say for all of you
anyway
keep going
whole thing is I don't care I mean money
has a factor yeah but I but that's like
my man probably already picture your
phone man yeah
wait what become a teacher I want to try
and make an impact with students they
can be a positive email a of course
rails been a positive impact on my life
since freshman year make sense you feel
me so many like that yeah well not kids
in high school you frame by one be like
a healthy puzzle role model for them
amazing amazing not gonna break the
bread anything uncodable money from
other job that's anything but teachers
are special teachers no okay cool I mean
you're educated I'm get mentor I can't
be anyone be just gotta let me in oh oh
so what's the question statement okay
that's right good yep okay how many
people go into college
raise your hand just curious how many of
the people that are going to college are
taking on debt like you're gonna have to
take debt to go to college raise it
that's my first piece of advice this is
real as [ __ ] everybody would just raise
their hand you have to ask yourself why
you're going to college I'm being
serious I know it's a tricky one
this is where I take heat but I'm saying
if you're not a student I was not a
student I would have not went to mount
high to college which was being nice :
into college but if my parents didn't
pay for it and that's what they wanted I
was cool with it because I knew I had
one last vacation before I was gonna
work the rest of my [ __ ] life I
wanted to wet it's I'm very scared that
everybody just blindly goes to college
cuz that's the American dream
and that's what's gonna put you on and
they take on that debt and then that
college degree doesn't put them on now
you have to have a viable option like if
I start a seed here and
your parents gonna be mad at me and you
decide not to go to college you got it
work so I just sit around but my first
piece advice my man is if you're taking
on debt and you're not going to a top 10
15 20 30 maybe top 100 university which
is gonna give you leverage when you get
out to get a job that might pay for the
debt that you're incurring you got a
debate you got a debate if you are then
it's different but even the top school
it's crazy what's happening so fast
biggest companies in world are no longer
requiring college debt is real interest
rates are real on it
people cut you many kids in here look
like everything's great are 140,000 debt
underwater making sixty four thousand
here not saving [ __ ] nobody uses 10% 30%
40% but nonetheless debt debts the first
thing I'm worried about after that the
people there's nobody in this room and
out here going to a college that's gonna
teach them something in the classroom
that isn't available on the internet for
free it's scary but who you meet things
like that nature but you can do that on
DM you can go then trip like the P the
people are the ROI but the people you
can get in real life too without the
debt got to know yourself got to be self
aware if you're not a real student if
you don't learn like that just go in
there because it's making your mom happy
or you think it's the right thing to do
if you're taking on debt you need to
reset I mean it I know that's you know I
know but [ __ ] the results speak
it's really return on investment like
you're gonna spend a Hyundai or a 63,000
or 49,000 in debt but you're compounding
712 percent interest after you get out
and you get a job that pays you like the
college was amazing from the [ __ ]
forty 50s to 90s because your degree put
you on to the job you got an accounting
degree and submit it in like some
accounting firm took you just not
happening anymore the same way I don't
know that's bad if you're taking on debt
you invest in something all that time
and money and you come out the other end
and it's not there for you what that's
why I keep death you go to college
stylist you go to college okay so to me
great enjoy amazing but even if you went
to fi t-- or what have you
like interning for the three biggest
designers in that same four year period
where they pay you five bucks an hour or
nothing to become a big-time stylist is
far more likely that path being a
student and coming out and trying to get
a job versus when you're the right hand
of the [ __ ] hottest stylists just cuz
you're carrying coffee but that when
your style and [ __ ] LeBron and they're
like Shetty's talent like that's real
life that's real life so self-awareness
would be my first advice on college
second if you decide if you listen
that's a big leap if you've been on a
course where like again cliche [ __ ]
you're gonna be the first one to ever go
or listen I get it it's a lot to like
just give up on cuz it's been in your
head the whole time if you go people if
you go people hello hello hello hello
hello friends friends different friends
my favorite thing I've talked about
recently was I went to USC and spoke to
them I'm coming out so I'm sorry I spoke
to the USC football team I walked in her
some [ __ ] you guys think you're
special you think you're cool I go 98
percent of you are not going in the
league this is it this is the apex of
your life this is the coolest the best
you'll ever be and I go and you're
walking into class at USC with your
[ __ ] hoodie on and your beats and
talking to nobody
meanwhile everybody in your classroom is
going to
run Hollywood in five years 20 years
wake the [ __ ] up that's how I think
about this like every kid you don't know
in school you should know people is the
game especially in high school
everyone's just making fun of each other
trying to be cool
making fun of people that could put them
on in ten years everybody who made fun
of me made a big [ __ ] mistake
[Music]
[Laughter]
yep what's up mother yep listen we're
taking internships and one of you guys
can have one well we're gonna have to
listen we're gonna have to figure out
how we're gonna do that contest nine
twenty twenty second two twenty two big
that's what's up man you guys come in my
office for your thing I'll I'll see you
guys a little bit before I leave all
right let's go what are we going come
behind my 30 how much